well I have a fun job but I'm not going
to talk about the fun parts I'm going to
talk about the problems that we've had
about the hard parts I want to start
with two questions the first question is
why do successful companies fail now I
grew up around this whole industry of
computers and as it went through this
remarkable revolution and saw a lot of
companies come and go but there were two
that stand out in my mind one was Evans
& Sutherland which is located in Salt
Lake and this is one of the pioneering
companies in computer graphics and they
had the lead they had more knowledge and
expertise than anybody else and they
were in the best position to take that
knowledge and go to the next level
because as a company but they made some
decisions that in which basically they
lost that lead and a new company left to
the front and that was Silicon Graphics
founded by Jim Clark who incidentally
used to work for Evans & Sutherland and
Ian etter sue me SGI had this remarkable
run they built the graphics machines it
was used throughout the world and for a
variety of visualization and graphics
techniques a lot of software was built
on it the the revolution in computer
graphics in the entertainment industry
was built on their machines they had
everything but they made two serious
mistakes and the things about these
serious mistakes was there were several
people on the outside to look at that
and say that's a really bad idea you
shouldn't do that
nevertheless they did it and they lost a
league they lost the lead to Nvidia it's
the only made up of former SGI employees
and they did some more remarkable things
and they with ata are still out in the
lead but the company that had that lead
was SGI and all the null
now the people that said they were
making the wrong decision in some way
they're like Cassandra where you're
telling the truth but the people don't
listen and Cassandra was cursed with
being able to see the future but not
having people believe her and it felt a
lot like that kind of situation here the
reason I start with this question was at
that time while this is going on I'm
with this struggling company and we're
trying to figure out how to make things
work and we start off with a company
it's just hard and that was pretty a
very difficult task but I'm thinking if
we're ever successful how do I keep from
falling into the traps these companies
are falling into and it's not like they
get blindsided by something which
catches him totally off-guard this stuff
is really pretty obvious they're missing
the obvious
the second question relates to a dinner
that I had with a studio executive that
the head of a studio a couple years ago
and he said at that activity' lunch he
said at that lunch our central problem
is not finding good people it's finding
good ideas so that was an interesting
expression so as I gave talks for the
next while after that I would pose that
question to the audience and ask them
whether or not they agreed with him and
what I found was that in every case the
audience was split 50/50 feeling pretty
astonishing didn't matter whether they
were students experienced business
executives artists high school teachers
they all split some thought he was right
I thought he was wrong well let me come
back to that second question later so
now let me step into the story which is
in 91 when our company was about five
years old and went through the various
hell as you go through and you starting
a company we finally got our chance and
we entered into a relationship with
Disney to make the first computer
animated film Toy Story
and at that time we got a few things
right we did have a culture where the
artists and the technical people were
peers with each other they socialized
with each other they each thought the
other was world class the compensation
structure was the same they were allowed
to intermarry if there are problems and
there were always problems people felt
comfortable about coming in and
expressing the problems we couldn't fix
every problem but it's important to hear
them the other thing we had was
something which we called the brain
trust
we had a certain group of people who
were very remarkable at telling stories
and part of being remarkable it was not
only that they were funny and focused
and good at storytelling but they had
complete trust in each other and they
were very and often what you might call
brutally honest except for them they
didn't think of it as brutally honest
they thought of as necessarily honest
and it was always taken that way it was
never a matter of a ego or putting
somebody down it was always about the
story and therefore he could say
something hard and it was taken the
right spirit and getting that kind of
camaraderie and a key group of people is
just gold and it's just it's an amazing
group and to this day it's an amazing
group of people so we got that right we
we had a review process that was
actually a combination of some things
that John I learned from Disney along
with things that were at ILM Lucasfilm
and but it was unique because of that
combination but what it amounted to was
that in the process of making the film
we reviewed the material every day now
this is counterintuitive for a lot of
people most people imagine this you
can't draw very well but even if you can
draw very well suppose you get you come
in and you've got to put together
animation or drawings and show it to a
famous world-class animator well you
don't want to show something which is
weak or poor so you want to hold off
into it until
get it to be right and the trick is
actually to stop that behavior we show
it every day when it's incomplete if
everybody does it every day then you get
over the embarrassment and when you get
over the embarrassment you're more
creative and that's a it's not obvious
to people but starting down that path
helped everything that we did show it in
its incomplete form there's another
advantage to doing that and that is when
you're done you're done now that might
seem silly except that a lot of people
they work on something and they want to
hold it and they want to show it let's
say two weeks later to get done only
it's never right so they're not done so
you need to go through this iterative
process and the trick was to do it more
frequently to change the dynamics also
as we started up in making this film we
brought in a new group of people because
we had artists we had technical people
but we never made a movie before so we
didn't have a group of people who are
really production managers they were the
ones keeping track of things making sure
the material from place to place you get
literally millions of things that are
going on there's a lot to manage a lot
to take care of so you needed people who
thought that way and we're experienced
with it so this is this new group coming
in from Los Angeles so we finished the
film and the film was a big success went
way beyond what anybody thought was a
great start to this new field of
computer animation and we are building a
company we have we went public at that
time that we went public
one week after film opened and it was
the biggest IPO of the year in fact and
we wanted people to see the product
before they invested and it just went
well it was a great whurling event but
at that time we're just just prior to
going public we had to start on the next
film because you can't just have one
product and that's it you've got to keep
coming out with them and we're very
aware there's a second product syndrome
where you kind of overdo in the second
one and you
and you blow it so we got somebody
working on the second one and as a team
start to roll off a toy story would
begin to put them on the new film which
is bug's life and so then we met with
the artists and so this is great let's
move on to the next film we met with the
technical people and it's a great we're
ready for it and we met with the
production managers they said what we
don't like it here you know we want to
quit so we undercover this major problem
they felt like they were second-class
citizens I feel like people treated him
second-class so I went around and asked
people among the artists in that
technical people and sure enough they
thought the production managers were
second-class
it's all true they thought they were
impediments that they were getting in
the way of getting the job done so we
had this major disaster so the first
question is what was the problem and
then I want to come back to the to the
deeper thing for me we making a movie is
a very organized activity so what was
happening is because it's so organized
there's so much stuff going on you can
easily lose control of it that we had
this very hierarchical structure in
place and the various people there
wanted to make sure that all the
information went through the proper
channels as it went up the hierarchy and
down the hierarchy so that everything
happened in the right place and that
whole notion of controlling that
information flow pissed everybody off
and yet there was a feeling he had to
maintain control the key concept we
realized at that time was that we had
confused the organizational structure
with the communication structure very
common thing that happens a lot of
companies they are different yes you
must be organized things must happen in
order you can lose control but
communication needs to be able to happen
between anybody in the company at
anytime it really is its peer-to-peer
right it's the notion you can go to any
anybody else yes let your managers know
but you have to go anywhere and
open-door policy frequently means you
can go to the head of the company but
open-door policy to us means anybody can
go to anybody anytime very important and
once we actually broke that down things
change dramatically the other part of
that though and this is the harder thing
for people to realize and that is that
for managers the one thing you hate as a
manager is to be surprised so you don't
like to walk in a meeting and find out
something for the first time in the
meeting in fact it's kind of a sign of
disrespect if you weren't told before
the other people in the meeting
if you've got everybody thinking that
way you got a problem so one of the
trick for managers is to learn is you
don't need to be the first person to
learn don't get upset
get over it it actually doesn't matter
in fact that somebody else talked about
the problem ahead of time is a good
thing not a sign of disrespect okay so
the other question which was the
difficult one for me was why had I
missed this problem we're off making
this film every was having a good time
and I'm looking for I thought I had a
great relationship opened or everything
like that totally missed it well part of
the reason was that there was a group of
new people that came into an existing
structure they accepted it they were
used to reporting to producers and if
you didn't like it we only had a job for
four months and just put up with it
you'd move on so there was no no reason
for them the complaint just put up with
it the other problem though was that
they really did like the fact that they
were working on a groundbreaking film
it's very exciting to be making history
they loved that they loved working for
John Lasseter so realized that because
they loved a lot of things they're
willing to put up with stuff that they
didn't like and this is one of the
fundamental problems I think with
companies and that is that success hides
problems it happens to a lot of us in
our personal lives with our health when
our healthy let me do a lot of things
that are bad for us but our help let's
just get away with doing stuff that's
bad for us
then years later the logic at that time
doesn't hold up but we do that it
happens with a lot of companies it
happens with state local and national
governments when you're healthy and
you've got the resources you don't need
to address the problems and when I look
at a lot of the companies look at this
guy and and so forth they were actually
very healthy and they're very strong and
the problems were there
but they didn't have to look at him at
that time they let the success and they
were successful that time they let that
get in the way of diving deep and
defining the problems so even though I
was kind of aware of this problem I been
caught by it too so just being aware of
it wasn't enough so that the the next
stage for us while we're making bugs
life is is we started to make a sequel
to Toy Story now the logic initially
which came from Disney was if you have a
successful film you need to have
follow-on things to keep the characters
alive and at that time it was to make
direct-to-video sequels so we picked a
couple of animators to give them a
chance to direct this picture put
together a team start to make this film
well right away we went into a problem
and that was the one group was making a
direct-to-video sequel which is
essentially like B or C level of
expectation and quality on the other
team the a team was working on bug's
life where you've got the very best
people and the expectation is we have to
match Toy Story well this wasn't good we
realized you got two different standards
of quality under the same roof realize
this actually isn't good for our souls
to do that we you know we shouldn't be
thinking that's okay to be doing
something which isn't great so fairly
early on we actually stopped that we
decided to make Toy Story a theatrical
release so we decided that okay we've
got to go for the a quality now incident
when you make a film when you start to
make it it isn't very good when you put
the wheels together you get the story if
it's really good
you're almost done all right but when
you're starting you're not almost done
so you've got to go through a lot of
steps to get there and what you want to
see is every six months or three months
whenever you you do really want to see a
step forward and sometimes you make a
step back but in general you want to
take that step forward what we found was
this was sort of hovering around not
being very good and just lots of issues
weren't right and
the directors didn't get along and the
producers were having problems and it
wasn't a very functional team so I went
to John who's focused on bug's life and
suddenly we got a problem here he says
don't worry the trust the process it'll
get to be better well I wasn't getting
me better so in 1998 bug's life was
finished and there was a worldwide tour
and John went on that tour but he knew
that when he returned that he then had
addressed the issue of Toy Story 2 a toy
story - as he returned had to be
delivered in 9 months all right so it
was already a tight schedule for they
were so he came back he watched Toy
Story 1 before he came into work from
his from his trip to Europe came in
watched the reels and walked in and said
you're right we've got a major problem
so basically we took the a-team we put
him on the project we went down to
Disney and said the film isn't good
enough we have to throw it away and
start all over again and the answer was
well actually it's better than you think
we think it is good enough but more
importantly it's too late you literally
do not have the time between now and to
deliberate to redo this film so we said
it's not good enough and we know we
don't have enough time but we're going
to do it anyway so we came back John
told the story to crew to take a good
rest over the holidays and come back in
January second we were we were reborn in
the movie so we then started and we had
eight months left we then started this
incredibly intense effort to get this
movie out it was boarded quickly it was
pitch to the company was an electrifying
pitch we had a lot of overachieving
people working for overachieving
managers had to get the movie out worked
brutal hours with this when I say brutal
we had a number of people that were
injured with RSI when I'm permanently
left the field we had actually a married
couple that worked there and this isn't
she
so it's summer and the father was
supposed to go out the baby off at
daycare but forgot don't know why but
came and left the baby in the car and
came into work and again and as the heat
was rising the mother asked about they
realized they rushed out the baby was
unconscious
the right thing was done they put ice
water on the baby and the baby ended up
being fine in the end but it's one of
those traumatic things like why did this
happen and they were working too hard
so when I saved some tents I mean it
really was intense so when the film was
finished on time and it was a huge
success
many people think that it was better
than the first one but we learned
several things from that one I should
say on the TV working so hard we we
adopted new ways the way we work in
terms of the RSI we hired full-time
economist and a doctor nurse coming in
twice a week a masseuse is available all
the time we limit the number of hours
people can work the whole number of
things that we instituted and really got
people to take this seriously at Pilates
and yoga classes stock everything just
to keep people physically fit to realize
they're in for the long haul
the reason I say this though is because
it's kind of a side note but it turns
out that this program cost money which
of course we're going to do anyway but
what we found after we did this was that
the injury rate dropped dramatically the
insurance company lower their premiums
and the reduction in premiums more than
paid for the entire cost the program I
say that because some people think they
can't afford this kind of stuff and I
think the answer is it can be before and
should be on the issue of the film
itself so it wasn't working but what
wasn't that wasn't working because it
turns out the theme of the story was
actually the same was about a toy that
gets stolen by the the toy collector and
ultimately has to make this choice it
wasn't working as a movie and the reason
was that the movies coming out from
Pixar in Disney so you know that Woody's
going to end up with his original family
you know what the end is before you
start you don't have a movie so you need
to have people believe that he has a
real choice to make
and so when they came back and reported
it that's when they add Jesse's song who
talked about her growing up and she was
the darling of this little girl but the
little girl grew up and moved on and
that's really what happens and that was
her message to what it says yes you may
like the situation you were in but life
goes on
it changes you can't hang on to that and
that's something that's true all right
we all know that and because we can
relate to why it's there's a hard
decision that has to be made and so the
things that are put in the movie are to
get it so that it relates to decisions
that we all have seen or we can
appreciate and then we can therefore at
joy as a movie and it's what turns it
into a real movie instead of just some
cheap following so I come back to the
first question which is more important
the or what's the central problem
finding good ideas or finding good
people and the answer is very clear the
idea was the same if you have a good
idea and you give it to mediocre group
they'll screw it up if you give a
mediocre idea to a good group they'll
fix it or they'll throw it away and come
up with something else the other thing
to know is there is a confusion I think
that the people have and is because the
books and press kind of work this way
and we think about an idea let me think
of ideas for movies we think about ideas
for products and it's usually thought of
as some singular thing but the reality
is these successful movies as well
successful products have got thousands
of ideas there's all sorts of things
necessary to make it be successful and
you have to get most of them right to do
it and that's why you need a team that
works well together
now we had a development department at
the time and our development department
structured just as it was with other
studios that is it's a group of people
looking for ideas to make into movies
and as we went through this we realize
we're thinking about it in the wrong way
we the goal of development is not to
find good ideas it's to put together
teams of people that function well
together and that change just altered
the way we thought about making movies
and to this day this development
department is loved by the directors
because it's a support group it's not
something telling them what to do it's
not a gate it's a support group
the directors because we're director to
live in driven studio are the ones who
are responsible for the movie and
everything else is to support them on
the way we measure progress is how well
that team gets together because
initially the films they put together
they're a mess it's like everything else
in life the first time you do it it's a
mess and sometimes its label the first
time it's a failure but it's not even
the right word to use right it's just
like you get the first one out you'll
learn from it and the only failure is if
you don't learn from it you don't
progress so the way we measure it is
like is this team functioning well
together and it's a thing that's never
let us down when that team functions
well they will succeed when things are
going wrong they will fail so for me Toy
Story 2 was the defining moment for the
studio a third movie was our defining
moment it set the way we think about
things and still do around this time we
are successful through in success a lot
of people are jumping on the bandwagon
one of the unfortunate consequences is
that 2d animation in this country was
actually shut down because they thought
the audience lost the taste for 2d and I
just wanted 3d it's all nonsense had
nothing to do with the technology had to
do with a story but unfortunately people
like to copy the wrong the wrong things
now people do copy
things it's the bizarre thing because
copying in some ways is a form of
learning she can say well I'll learn
from what everybody else did and then
I'll copy that but in many respects it's
shallow it's sort of like if you think
about movies you know sometimes you see
people do a remake of a movie but you
alright you notice that they always we
make good movies and it really did I
beat the good movie but the fact is
there are thousands of movies out there
they're actually great idea but they're
poorly executed they should be making
bad movies or does it happen with
product the ones that do better aren't
those and just copy somebody else's good
product they actually take the thing
that's going wrong and fix that right
that's the better idea so any what we
found was almost everybody's kind of
copy what we're doing and they could
copy the technology but they couldn't
copy the process we were used to come up
with a story now even though we have
this great brain trust though a lot of
experience and learned all this things
didn't get any easier we kind of hoped
at some point you get under your belt
like it's easier but it didn't get
easier
so we instituted a process of doing post
forms after every movie trying to do a
deep analysis the first post mortems
were very successful we worked very hard
to make sure people were safe they
didn't get shot for pointing out
problems and everybody got a lot out of
them they valued them greatly
so we're off to a good start but then it
go on to the next post-mortem people
began to game the system and it turns
out people know the value they know they
should do them but they don't like to do
it so why don't they like to do the post
mortem so I don't like to do the
analysis well it kind of tirely we're
going something for three years they
don't want to think about anymore some
people are defensive some people feel
that that one of the things they want to
do in these meetings just make their
team feel good look what we did so it's
not really an in-depth analysis and
for us then the task is to keep pushing
this because unless we do the in-depth
analysis we will always go for the easy
thing because again it's when you're
successful when the film goes off right
you kind of like to stop at that point
you sort of bask in it and not dive
deeper so we what we found is we have to
change the way we do the post-mortems
every single film because the next film
they'll game it but if we can change it
in the right way then it will work so
the latest thing we're doing until he
gets game is we're asking them to pick
the from the process the five things
that they would do again and the five
things they wouldn't do again we try to
get both to get the balance what we're
really registered the things that they
wouldn't do again but you know you try
to get both out there on the other and
this fairly important one is to get a
lot of facts about the process when you
put the facts up in your fact driven it
actually stimulates discussion and it's
those discussions which are very
valuable you come out of that we have a
new theory about how to do things and we
would get it which we come up with a new
way of doing it and we get that every
time about two thirds right and
one-third wrong and you never know what
the mix is going to be but roughly it's
like one third of the stuff you're
traveling to do so you're just bogus
because you call it wrong but that's
okay at least you got two thirds right
so let me summarize a few things we've
learned one is the constant review
second is it must be safe for people to
tell the truth
third is the communication should not
mirror the organizational hierarchy
people and how they function is more
important than ideas and do not let
success mass problems do a deep
assessment now having said those things
is part of the culture of Pixar and well
there's another problem so let me set
this up by discussing another discovery
early on we we came to believe that the
story is the most important thing in a
process it led our decision-making
process and so as we had a lot of
different polls we've come back to this
driving principle
it's the story that counts and and we
thought this is one of the things that
made us successful this was this
realization and now so having said that
and we would say that we tell people
about it
when we made all the sacrifices for it
and then I discovered as I was listening
around that every studio says the same
thing everybody says the stories the
most important thing even if the story
was drivel it might be true that it is
true but it doesn't affect behavior now
if when I say stories the most important
thing I think the analogy with a lot of
companies probably qualities is the most
important thing is one of those things
is true you agree is true and you say it
that doesn't mean anything
now when I first started Pixar and I
came out of a pure technical background
I had to learn a lot about business
quickly and I hadn't gone to any school
so I just read a lot of books and there
were a few bits and pieces but I got to
say for the most part I didn't get a lot
of traction with him trying to variety
of things so I said well maybe the
problem is yeah I just got to get to the
essence of them so there's a service you
know that gets the summaries of business
books so I tried that and I read those
and that was actually an amazing
experience because in reading the
essence of the books I realized they
were content free
so well what's going on here is it the
fact that the book doesn't have any
content which is probably true in many
cases or which I another thing is is it
that you can't take some of these things
and reduce them in a meaningful way
which I suspect is also true I ran into
a similar thing this just happened a
while ago is some of the stories the
most important thing comes out of the
world of architecture and at that time
we were looking at building some a
building actually this last year and and
I know there's some buildings down there
which are abysmal just awful buildings
and so it's our talking with our
building person up at Pixar as we're
coordinating to get these built he
explained to me the concept in
architecture of building from the inside
or designing from the inside out as
opposed to the outside in and outside is
the bad room that you get the look of
the building and sort of that dictates
what you're doing you end up with poor
buildings and inside-out is where you
think about the function of the way
people work and that sort of dictates
things and you try to make it look good
from the outside so in that world inside
out is good outside in his bed so then I
met with an architect who was
responsible for one of the buildings and
he used the phrase that he designed the
buildings from the inside out
but the building he designed was was it
was a disaster so I rely arts the same
thing the phrase is important this
community he just doesn't have any
effect on behavior
so once the principle once one can
articulate an important idea into a
concise statement then one can use this
statement and not have to have the fear
of changing behavior and I just I see
this over and over again so if I can
summarize some of these things but the
real issue is what do we do why not not
in what we say about what are the things
that we do every product that weird
making has got to be original which
implies that we can never repeat
ourselves now this is to me it's an
important thing because a lot of people
Holly we actually don't understand that
if something is successful if you've got
stars or Shrek or in Star Wars or Shrek
or whatever then basically let's do that
again
alright well you make it a little bit
different we'll try to do the same thing
again but you can't think that way
with any products everything is new and
original and therefore our way of
dealing with and solving the problems
has got to be an original so the secret
is we have to keep on digging deeper and
deeper and knowing that we're always
missing something that's important so
let me return to the first question why
does successful companies fail no matter
why did golden ages end I do believe
that organizations human organizations
are inherently unstable they will fall
over and you have to work to keep them
upright but they fall slowly most people
don't notice it they let their success
high blind them they don't see it
falling over the following takes place
low but the collapse is quick you have
to do constant assessment you have to
look for the hard truths I mentioned
Cassander before it's the Greek myth and
again she's cursed with seeing the truth
but nobody will believe her I don't
think the Greeks had it right actually I
think the curse is on the people that
don't listen right we have to be the
ones who are looking for it all the time
and when we hear things evaluate it is
it right I think in the movies in our
process we have we have various crises
but there are two fundamental kinds of
crises one is that you don't like what
you see so you have to make changes now
the fact that you make changes is is not
in and of itself a crisis that's just
hard work what makes a crisis is there a
lot of people with a vested interest and
with positions and you've got to
actually rearrange things and it's and
it's people butting up against each
other and that's a hard thing to do it's
an emotional thing to do
but you do that and you end up making a
better film the second kind of crisis is
to release the film and the audience
doesn't like it now at that point it's
too late to do anything about it but the
difference between the two crises is it
the first one is self-imposed and that's
the important part now and in this talk
I focused on our problems and the tone
might be a little downbeat in some of
this but as I say I haven't talked about
the fun part but this approach and
thinking about it and always diving
deeper and questioning has let us
assemble the best people in the industry
it's the most extraordinary team I
worked with we are in this extraordinary
building up at Pixar that it's one of
the greatest places to work we have a
lot of fun together and a lot of
laughter and our job is to keep it going
thank
take some questions
in my opinion what they bought Cray
computer all right
the second one was they came out with a
an add-in PC board and it was not
successful and they reached the
conclusion that it was not a good idea
all right rather than saying the first
one's not successful what should we do
to make a successful because that
basically the way the whole industry is
structured now it was really the is not
taking the information they learn from
that first failure if you will and
turning into a success how do you
document this and how do you make sure
that this knowledge that you're gaining
is actually turning into something
practical was there somebody documenting
this and design writing down the process
to work on how would you do it fun is in
all of our meetings where the creative
or post morning we have no takers and
the image is either their staff members
but they're really good they just keep
track of everything the second thing is
that the people in preparing for it
actually get a lot of information it's
the people in charge who go through the
process and thinking through it get a
lot of their information and the people
who are then presented to are frequently
the leaders of a follow-on film so
there's a direct handoff in
communication and just having the
discussion surfaces a lot of issues so
it is a variety of things excuses why
they done to it are frequently like I've
already started the next process so the
too late the post-mortem happens too
late for me so there are things like
that which get in the way in addition to
people not wanting to do it so it's I
mean for me it's saying okay we all know
it's good but it's like your medicine
you know you got to do it or stuff your
vitamins it's something you take need to
do it yes
people actually like that
the process of GAD gathering the
evidence is is mixed that is we're
fairly good at it while we're getting
better at it but their number of times
you get something you haven't kept track
of all the detail in general when we
actually gather the facts and we present
it then the reaction of most people is
like they're just fascinated by it
because they're flying by their gut
which is pretty good but there are
things they missed the facts show and
people that let facts a override
judgment but it actually is it sometimes
gives you pictures you can't see
otherwise so it's very well appreciated
at Pixar and we've got fact there's a
graduate from Stanford University or
Ghana who's he was brilliant and he is
extremely good at getting taking facts
in teasing out important information and
you present that important information
really concise ways and just it's things
that people didn't see before
so the fact they see that means they
want to participate and helps them
commit to to gathering facts in the
future so it's a it's a very successful
way of working yes yes this code I think
their book they got to go hand-in-hand
so have you literally - conclusive that
at least should go together and opposed
to is like one verse together okay where
the ideas come from it's the the reason
for phrasing it that way because you
essentially need the new and the fresh
ideas is what you're doing is giving
credit and camaraderie to a team of
people you can't give that to an idea
and what you're trying to do is have the
people work well together so I'd much
rather say the people are the important
thing and they're going to come up with
the ideas if I say the idea is the
important thing and it's not okay what I
do want to come up with you know you
have to you have to support them so
that's why I do put
the people first because the ideas are a
process that results from the people
working well or they bring the result of
people working well together yes two
quick things first is there any way to
share the kickstart process with the
Pentagon and the State Department White
House how do you track audience how you
segment and track audience interests and
is that something that's changed and
evolved over time as you as you're doing
these films well on the first question
oh god I wish now I actually do believe
there's a notion of self assessment
which is is unfortunately lacking I'm I
think one of the things if I look at
they at the left and the right
fundamentally they don't they actually
don't trust people the thing I like
about the the center is that it's more
based on trust not that mistakes aren't
made but I look at the extremes the like
it's like we're going to impose
something and it's not a trusting
mechanism and the I think the notion of
self assessment is a political it
doesn't matter you know where the
Republican or Democrat some people sort
of get the notion of honest assessment
and some people don't because they've
got an agenda you know and we all know
that and we know we see the results and
we talk about I said when a golden age
is general you know even at the national
level are we guaranteed that America
will be great in 200 years we've no
guarantees we have no guarantees any
company will be around or you know it
just all of it requires constant
diligence in a thought process which is
say we have responsibility and making it
better as far as heading for an audience
we don't we don't target a group like
once every we're going after we don't go
after kids all right it's a bad idea to
target films for little kids for two
reasons one is essentially is talking
down to them and if you talk down to
them they don't like it that much
and for adults it's very boring the
truth is children live in an adult world
and they're used turning things they
don't understand so our approach is we
want to make movies that we enjoy
there's a physical humor humor and
physical comedy that comes from acting
from animation the kids do enjoy so
there's a thing that they do like and
obviously we don't put in things into
our movies that would offend families or
their children but we write the dialogue
on the story for us we want them to be
meaningful to us and that's how we think
about it we will do some late screenings
after the stories farewell along partly
because if you've seen a movie over and
over again you actually lose perspective
on it
so sometimes you just need to have
somebody who's never seen it before and
you just sit there in the room and it
sort of opens up your eyes you don't
even record anything you just see things
there's different so and that's more the
way that the feedback works yes your
banter with services it looks like a
brilliant move now but I'm wondering ten
years ago was it transform that company
and the culture was obviously
well in when he formed the company we
spun off from Lucasfilm and initially we
sold a hardware product which is an
image computer and then that was rough
that's why he's reading all the books
and I got advice I called Jim Clark and
the head of Sun I'm playing a blank here
Scott McNealy for advice and turns out
that a well-meaning advice but turns out
it was the wrong advice because it
wasn't appropriate we're doing I didn't
know enough to sort of figure some of
this out and we were just it was hard
and we got into the software business we
that we then did the rent amount of
software and we started doing
commercials but I got to tell you we
can't lose the money didn't matter what
we did the one nice thing was is that
our Investor was Steve Jobs and now mind
you I mean in one sense Steve is it's
like he's not known for being patient
but the reality is that he was patient
with us right he was funding our
education and so whether time we got the
chance for the big one which was the
movie we've been through a lot we had
bonded together as a team and he fun of
that education but then it came back in
spades because we worked together with
him as a team to to build this rather
remarkable place and it was really cool
really to have an investor sort of
understood what we're doing and what we
were going for which really helped
change the industry so we moved over
into filmmaking so we're actually not in
service anymore except for like we do
still sell render man so it's just
really nice business it's almost all the
special effects you see in movies are
using the software that we sell and I
mean they're it's the only piece of
software that we do sell we don't sell
any of our other animation software
because we think there's a certain
advantage we have but in this case we
like the fact that there's an
industry-wide standard yeah
successful process of telling stories
the tag that you work with animated
actors instead of real life actors and
where do you see the industry heading
well when we make films question is
animated active versus live-action
actors the characters in our films are
really a combination of the the writers
and the story team putting it together
the design and the animators and the
physical acting and the voice of the
actor since we picked and select actors
who've got really remarkable voice it's
really that collection that creates a
character and it's just missed part of
the animation so it's just different
than live-action the time scale is
different the way that it's put together
is different and then both live-action
animation you can also do it badly and
you can do it well it just depends upon
talent yes the Pixar is something to
spin off and obviously there'll be
another very successful in the spin-offs
like Photoshop and Digital Domain and
tell telling others what is it what is
it about Lucas entrance that makes them
successful entrepreneurs and do you see
the same characteristics in Disney
veterans
well the George Lucas was really
remarkable in that having produced Star
Wars he believed that bringing
technology into the industry would
benefit it and so the job that I was
given when I came into Lucasfilm in 1979
was to bring high-technology into the
industry so I'm a digital audio video
editing computer graphics and games so
nobody else was funding in this industry
except for George so I was able to go
out and hire the best people in each one
of these areas so that was a great
activity being engaged with now in the
end it's a filmmaking company and he had
sort of like this hot bit of ideas and
good people so there's some spin out
from that so this was a computer
division within ILM they didn't actually
spin out of the companies was actually
people who is because they were
successful
that some people were stolen away to
start competing companies but it wasn't
as if Highland would spend them out and
in the case of Photoshop the original
one was written by John Knowles who is
there the Knowles brothers one of whom
is still there and is a soup tech for
making films and other remarkable one
but it was early sold off to Adobe it's
big changes actually been through Adobe
but part of it is there's something
about the environment you've got
technology and art together that's a
great mix and it's a nice place to be
and if you think about it and most
people don't think about this way
because they think of films like the
old-fashioned but when Walt Disney
started off back in the 30s with this it
was a technological revolution films
were new color was new sound was new
maybe the first one to put sound in
there he first wouldn't put color he
locked up Technicolor for a while so
there a lot of things even he was
adopting every technology as it came
along and that mix of the technology and
the artists provided or made this
environment where a lot of cool things
were happening and you look back in the
past and you sort of focus on the art
without realizing what was the
environment that made that and over
awhile that environment sort of went
away and then the new environment
basically picked up at Lucasfilm then at
Pixar where there's the mix of the
artists and the technical together and
and now realizing that and seeing what
happened then what happened now it's
very important for us to keep the
technology changing keeping it keep it
mixed mixed up sometimes the individuals
don't always see that they look it from
their point of view but you have to look
at it as a whole ecosystem and having
that mixture together which sort of like
what universities supposed to be right a
lot of things happening in one place
just stimulates you to think about
things in new and innovative ways back
there you successfully manage Pixar
without your technical background
do this to that
well I don't know I always look at that
Pixar's really having the combination of
a variety of people there and I brought
one way of looking at things John
brought something Steve Jobs brought
something and there are various other
people who brought something to the mix
and it was the balance you know there
are there things that could have gone
wrong in that and then it wouldn't have
happened but you know and none of us
even points say you know any of us did
it alone it really took all of us
together to do that so I can't so I
can't separate out my background say
well what do I have done different you
know I am Who I am and each one of those
is different in a complementary way and
we're very different from each other but
but that difference is our strength yes
ix
sort of assessment of selling renderman
is that you're enabling your competition
can you explain kind of how you look at
that internally and why you continue to
believe that that's the right strategy
for the company and why it helps to
raise the level of excellence at Pixar
well any piece of software like that
they require it requires a great deal of
work to keep it in a good place and we
have a lot of things going on there's
certain things that we actually invented
in the first place but now we buy
commercially when we did the first paint
program the first compositing right but
in fact we don't do them we do them as
commercial products it is to our
advantage to have an industry-wide
standard if we didn't sell it there
would be another one and then it would
be a pain in the neck because we would
be different than the rest of the studio
in something that needs to be across the
studio and it now costs two Studios so
in that case we're better off having an
industry-wide standard that for me the
technology is part of the culture it is
a we have some competitive advantage in
several of the things we do with
technology but I do think that the
biggest competitive advantage is the way
we work with have the technology that
created work together the things I've
been talking about it's actually the
thing that if somebody hears it they'll
probably copy the wrong
piece of it so like you know I can tell
them with any what's important it won't
matter you know so just say I understand
that the stories the most important
thing and that in fact I is his thing if
somebody else figures it out then
they'll tell they'll make good stories
we're also in a funny industry where the
competitors are our competitors for the
weeks that you're out and the rest of
the year you actually want them to do
well if people go to movies and they
have a bad experience as a competitors
movie have a bad experience then that
sort of takes away their enjoyment from
going to the movies you know they have a
lot of bad experiences they won't go to
movies if they go have a great time then
they'll want to go more so we want our
competitors to do well except when our
movies out all right
then they can burn and die thank
[Applause]